make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
okay every time I make a beyond
omega-level video and I do mean like
every time I ask you guys who you want
to see me covered next right I always
say that like let me know in the
comments section who you want me to
cover next and everybody not really
everybody but like lots of you guys
always respond with the same person not
of a person with the same character so
today I'm granting your requests and we
are going to do a Beyond omega-level
video on Shue McGrath so who is Shuma
gorath alright for those of you guys who
are fans of the Marvel vs. Capcom games
you already know that he's basically
just like a giant one-eyed green octopus
that was inexplicably included in
several games in that series but as for
the comic book version Shue McGrath was
created by Steve Englehart and
frankfurter and debuted in Marvel
premiere number 5 in 1972
now as for his origin Shue McGrath has
been around longer than the Marvel
multiverse itself he's basically a super
ancient demonic entity belonging to a
species known as the mini angled ones
that essentially exists in the space
between realities now the goal of the
mini angled ones is to infiltrate and
eventually conquer and corrupt realities
until everything that exists within that
reality is devoted to worshipping them
we actually saw that play out during the
story of Thanos imperative if you never
actually seen it check out the link in
the description it's really really good
anyway among the many angled ones Shue
McGrath is considered one of the most
powerful belonging to a subset of the
race known as the old gods of which
there were only four known members now
what we know about Shue McGrath is
somewhat limited but we do know that he
ventured to earth millions of years ago
and ruled over the entire planet but was
banished to a different dimension by a
sorcerer from the 31st century named
sighs Meg which is Genesis spelled
backwards
ah which is kind of weird anyway he ends
up traveling in time collecting all the
magical energy he can in hopes of
reaching the beginning of all creation
and remaking it in his image in the
process sighs Meg becomes nearly
omnipotent but the last thing sighs Meg
does before remaking the universe is to
banish you McGrath to another dimension
but he acknowledges that if he attacked
Shu McGrath directly the old one would
simply siphon off too much of his energy
and he wouldn't be able to defeat him
and so seeing that Shu McGrath was
devouring all of the primates that
existed on earth at the time sighs Meg
put Shu McGrath in a deep sleep before
sending him to a different dimension
now Schumacher
would not remain in exile forever and he
would actually return to Earth during
the Age of Conan the Barbarian which
makes sense because the name Xu McGrath
was actually lifted by Steve Englehart
from a short story by Robert E Howard
the creator of the entire Conan mythos
and so Marvel Comics actually published
an ongoing Conan common from 1970 to
1993 and toward the end of that run in
1991 it was revealed that Xu McGrath had
returned to Earth and had been
imprisoned within a mountain by a shaman
in the service of the deity qualm and
upon being released by a group of
sorcerers was banished from Earth by
Conan using Ironbound magic texts now
the next time we see sure McGrath is
when he's trying to get back to earth
via the mind of the ancient one and this
is probably the instance that most of
you guys are most familiar with when it
comes to his character but the ancient
one as most of you guys probably know
was dr. Strange's mentor in the mystic
arts one of the most prolific sorcerers
in the Marvel Universe and the former
sorcerer supreme of Earth and so this
takes place in the pages of Steve
Englehart run on Marvel premiere when he
first introduced the character of Shu
McGrath and what we find out is that Shu
McGrath sought out the ancient one
because he was the pre-eminent force of
good in all the cosmos this made him
basically the opposite of Shu McGrath
who states that he comes from a
dimension that is diametrically opposed
to the main Marvel Universe which
essentially means that Shu McGrath is
the strongest force for evil in all of
existence for the more Groth tells dr.
strange that the ancient one knew that
he would never be able to defeat him and
reveals his plan to kill Stephen strange
and supplant every religion on earth so
that all the warships Shu McGrath
instead and so with earth conquered
gorath would then move on to conquering
the rest of the universe something he
could probably actually do but we
marking the Shu McGrath is the most
powerful foe that he's ever faced Doctor
Strange launches a desperate bid to
prevent his return to Earth by shrieking
himself down and entering the mind of
the ancient one now when he finds the
ego of the ancient one strange destroys
it and in doing so destroys his physical
body as well effectively killing him now
strange remarks that Kelly the ancient
one is the only way to stop zoom agura
--then states that the life of the
ancient one must be weighed against the
life of everyone else in the universe
indicating that Stephen strange believed
that Shu McGrath was capable of
accomplishing his goal of conquering the
entirety of reality itself now following
this we've seen gorath attempt to return
to Earth several times but he's
typically repelled before he's actually
able to do so and this is what makes it
difficult to really get a sense of how
powerful
McGrath is and wife held off so long on
doing a video on him he's typically
described as being nyama 'putin and
substantially more powerful than demons
such as Mephisto who had said looks like
a mouse in a great temple compared to
Shu McGrath unfortunately however we see
Shu McGrath being banished back to his
home dimension before he's able to reach
his true form and therefore he's unable
to perform any of the feats that gives
us a true picture of his power now in
terms of what his powers are Shu McGrath
seems to essentially be immortal as he's
existed for millions of years and no
matter how many times he appears to be
vanquished
he always reimburse for instance once
dr. strange killed himself in the same
fashion that he killed the ancient one
to prevent himself from transforming
into Shu McGrath of course strange was
later resurrected from his fate and Shu
McGrath was also reformed because comics
he does seem to be close to omnipotence
as well as it's revealed during an
encounter with dr. strange the Shu
McGrath is the ruler of hundreds of
alternate dimensions now one of the
realities ruled by Shu McGrath and the
Meany angled ones of course is the
cancerverse which was a near-perfect
copy of one six until Marvel contracted
cancer unlike the main Marvel Universe
from Marvel actually died of his cancer
and the cancer verse he accepted a
bargain for the Meany angled ones that
allowed them to destroy the abstract
concept of mistress death and then
corrupt that entire universe itself
now Shu McGrath is capable of reality
manipulation having created a perfect
replica of Earth and was able to use it
as a voodoo doll of sorts for the real
earth surrounding it with a band of
flames which can be felt on earth itself
he can travel across dimensional and
physical barriers manipulate matter and
take on any shape he desires he can
drain energy from his surroundings and
his opponents and is a strong enough
telepath that he can communicate
psychically with beans in other
dimensions he's able to project powerful
energy blasts had destroyed planets and
is said to be capable of destroying
galaxies at will which would definitely
place him well beyond Omega level so
yeah that's basically Shu McGrath we
don't really know much about him right
like I wish there were more feats for us
to discuss but the characters mostly
just been used as kind of like an
abstract threat like this threat is just
kind of looming out there and may or may
not return something along those lines
he's something that's capable of
destroying everything but that's always
been thwarted in order to make sure he
doesn't get a foothold in reality but as
it is we don't really know what would
happen if Shu McGrath's true form were
ever realized in the main Marvel
Universe but enough has been said about
him by reliable narrators like Doctor
Strange and the ancient one that we can
basically be
his ability to destroy really like earth
easily galaxies and probably conquer the
universe if he ever reached his full
potential phenomenal you guys think
right it's kind of a weird situation let
me know what you guys think I wish there
was more that we could cover it up but
again
Shuma broth is just kind of an ambiguous
threat that looms out there or that
means that guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and that will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]